so there's just a lot of superhero news
lately and you know with the Avengers
teaser and the spider-man T's and the
Dark Knight teaser and all these set
photos and everything who would have
thought that for a movie that got pushed
back to 2013 that is like my for two
years they released the first official
photo of Henry Cavill as Superman I've
always really liked Superman growing up
when I was a kid I used to love the
original movies with Christopher Reeve
who was brilliant I mean a Superman no
one in my opinion will ever really be
able to replace him if there is a such
thing as perfect casting I think that
Christopher Reeve was that he was just
everything Superman needed to be but I
even like the old serial cartoon that
they used to run on TV I watched that a
lot and I even watched the Lois and
Clark TV show with Dean Cain which is
corny but when I was a kid I loved it
Superman Returns which I thought was a
good film that maybe got the tone of
Superman a little wrong but I still
enjoyed it and now Zack Snyder's working
on the Man of Steel it's coming out in
here's the first look at Superman now I
personally actually really like this it
looks a little more like Superman's a
little more angrier and I like that we
needed a Superman movie where he can
fight and kick some butt because really
the only good Superman movie that we've
had where he does that is Superman -
because in Superman Returns it's very
much like Superman in the movie it was
him and Lex facing off and all different
types of obstacles that the Superman has
to deal with but let's face it Superman
3 and 4 yeah he fought people in that
movie but those movies suck so really
Superman 2 is really the only film we've
been able to see Superman kick butt and
it was really well done for its time of
course I really liked the look of his
cape it looks very matrix it looks huge
and big and that's good because in the
comics Superman's cape is supposed to be
like an indestructible odd vivid he uses
to protect himself and other people
and in the other movies that was just
came off more it's like a piece of cloth
but in this picture it looks a lot more
like a formidable object in its own and
it looks like Zack Stein was gonna do a
lot of visual stuff for the cape - he's
you know he's a very visual director and
it might be really interesting to see
some of the stuff he's gonna do if
Superman because yes sir miss films kind
of lack in the storytelling Department
at times but they always look very good
and I'm excited to see what he can do
with Superman also the main symbol it
looks a lot like the earlier Superman
symbol and the early
comics where you have it was very fat
and bubbly and everything and I like it
it looks good his suit sort of looks
like it's made of bubble wrap and still
bumps and stuff all over that's kind of
what Spiderman started I think with a
little with the look of the non fabric
look but more of a like a latex kind of
thing going on I don't know I like it
what are your thoughts on it I think it
looks really cool I can't really get
pumped for a movie that doesn't come out
for two years but it's nice to see
something that looks like Superman is
being treated well so yeah those are my
thoughts on that today I'm gonna see a
rise of the Planet of the Apes sticking
long title and I'll let you guys know
what I think of that later